what the heck
no no no no come on
i'll get my hand pan and play a little
ditty if
welcome back welcome back nika wants the
banjo
i'm so disappointed but don't worry the
all right there we go it's not even in
tune
no banjo's ever in tune sounds great
[Music]
all right jake come on play play me
according come on
podcast all right cool now the mood is
set it's like having a wine with your
fancy dinner it's like
you gotta you gotta do it you know it's
like having some cheese with your
favorite cracker
they bring over the wine and then you
sample it have you ever
been like no this one no sorry
no send it back
have you ever tasted a wine you know
they bring it over you take that little
sip
have you ever rejected it i i i feel
like someone needs to do it just to say
that they've done it
so i've never done i have seen a drink
back but it was never
i never did it with wine what did you do
it with
you know zinc or bar mateo down the
street yeah
so you know they like to think they're
hoi toy in a really fancy restaurant
when in reality they're a good
restaurant but they're definitely not
like
20 cocktail kind of restaurant but they
they're
you know they're getting a little big
for their shoes and this guy's talking
up this really good drink and it's like
kind of pricey i'm like all right
i have an hour on a date let's let's
order it
i get this like it's a salty like
whipped cream
kind of drink and i get back and it's
like like the kind of froth you'd have
on top of a beer
with like a bunch of salt and then like
ice and water
or like vodka tasting water and it's
like this is
gross this is the grossest drink i've
ever had and it's like
18 i'm like sorry guys
i need a different one give me a
different one that you know you spend
some effort
on please but didn't you did you
actually give it back you didn't finish
it
i actually gave it back to them i took
two sips of it and i asked for a
different one
that's really important because if you
don't give it back
then you look like a huge [ __ ] you
know what i mean
i was having dinner the other week and
there's a table next to me
already they're like complaining about
the seating they're like oh this could
be really weird if we
you know they had like six or seven
people the only free table
was one that fit four so they're already
complaining like oh this could be weird
sitting here it's like i don't know it's
really uncomfortable it's like
guys it's the only seat and then
on top of that they all order drinks
the drinks come they immediately raise
their hand the waiter comes over they're
like
uh these drinks are way too like weird
and syrupy can we like get something
else
and they're like he's like sure yeah
yeah of course you want me to take the
drinks back and like no we'll finish
them
[Laughter]
so what is it do they suck or not like
i just it's just like that that attitude
you have
commitment you know decision making
decisiveness
yeah so send the banjo back
so send the banjo back did you send the
banjo back
is that what just happened there i
didn't send the banjo back i thought the
banjo was great
you brought it back is what you did yeah
you
i brought it back by popular demand by
one person's
insistent demand over and over wouldn't
it be funny if somebody in the
in this podcast just goes on every video
and comments
this is great but what happened to the
banjo
and everyone's like dude didn't you hear
it it was at the beginning
just every episode they just keep
commenting
yeah or we just you know we stop the
banjo but then
we keep telling people that it's in it
when they ask us like it's in this video
why aren't you seeing it like i see it
it's at the beginning yeah yeah yeah
we act like it's there and i just don't
actually play it
[Laughter]
exactly just to really confuse people
i don't know who knows maybe we'll vfx
it
go nico yeah we all just spent a week in
texas yeah yeah jake has
now now permanently spending multiple
weeks in texas
[Laughter]
how's your slurp coming it's coming
along yeah we got
some good uh some good bits we have some
good slurp bits afterwards
we figured out what slurp actually is
made of
so for those of you who don't know every
time we go to texas
the the idea of a slurp
comes to be and we're not exactly sure
what it is it's just something that you
use in uh
in in speaking like um it's like a
combination of like
it's it's like a half like yokel half
draw
half like spittoon you know like it's
all these elements combined into one
concept of slurp
and then if you instead of saying like
um when you're using a sentence
you think
can you can you give me an example yeah
so uh so i was gonna go on down to the
creek there
but and
and i was seeing some some little kinds
of fishes
but i didn't have my fishing rod
so now look listen if you if you are
from texas then you
you know we're talking about you can
skip this bit
[Laughter]
we also we also evolved the uh the heb
references
so yeah so there's a grocery store out
here called h-e-b
which is the the the initials of the guy
that started it
but we always yeah
that's what you gotta do right there
yeah so we we we started calling it heb
having a good time and then it became
and then it became synonymous with here
what y'all doing heaven
[Laughter]
and then have have you ever seen a
have you ever seen a texas have you ever
seen a texas slurp
and have you ever seen an ash skin bale
and then and then it evolved into [ __ ]
which is like that really fancy people
say it
they're like yeah okay but
uh i need to go to eve
please listen honey could you pick me up
something at the [ __ ]
except oh boy
yeah it's pretty brutal out there yeah
texas will change you
it will it'll turn you before you know
it you'll be slurping and heaving all
the way back
[Music]
yeah slurping in heben try heebs
so while you were um well we were out
there
you were in la making a bunch of videos
i was
um what did you guys what did you guys
make did you
did you feel a sense of complete and
utter loss
in our absence nico yeah i did just real
quick sam what do you got your fingers
there
that little thing in your hands it's a
tiny simba on a suction cup
it's not a suction cup did you get that
in a happy mail
it looks like gideon got that in happy
mail no he won it at the grocery store
for being super cute
oh perfect wow perfect yes all right
cool so uh yeah that's packet back in
the studio uh we did some really cool
things
like ren made our heads into ice cubes
so like
somebody sent us this little like mini
vacuum former like a desktop vacuum
former yeah yeah and like the thing
that's cool about it it uses a shop
vac as the vacuum part so it's basically
just a fancy toaster at that point
and you toast up your plastic and you
slam it down to the thing the shop pack
sucks the air out uh so it actually
works
um and the idea is that you know you can
3d print you can take pictures of the
head
somebody's head ham and uh you can take
pictures of the head
and then you can 3d print that grocery
store
uh no you take 3d pictures of somebody's
face and you can 3d print that
and then you use that as basically a
mold uh for the vacuformer to vacuform
a piece of uh plastic over it um and
then you can fill it with water and you
can make an ice cube
or you can make it jello but basically
long story short you get to make
molds of your face to fill with water or
ice or whatever so we did that last week
that was fun
it was like it's a good like not too
productive but still entertaining video
concept
and then we also did uh remaking tron's
cgi which in my opinion was uh
like probably the the cooler of the two
concepts not like reagan wren's video
but you know we had just done a visual
effects artist react episode to tron
looking at the original from 1982 and
like
all the crazy stuff they had to do to do
that cgi back in the day you know it's
they're basically working on this movie
with like no tools whatsoever
um you know just doing the most routine
and tedious stuff by hand
in the computer like for example you
know when you're animating something
on a computer these days you know you
frame frame one you put it in one
position
frame 10 put it in the other position
you have a keyframe for each one of
those
and then the computer will automatically
move the object from
its position at frame one to its
position at frame 10 over those frames
right it's called tweening in betweening
it's the same thing for animation you
have
a keyframe artist that draws one frame
and he draws the next frame 10 frames
later and they have all the scrub
artists do all the in-betweens
yeah so you know easy stuff for a
computer
that's the official that's an industry
term yeah the scrub
artist that's an industry term that
disgemed
so uh so you know but you know their
computer programs are doing 3d
imaging and stuff like they didn't even
have like scrub under this they didn't
even
in between they didn't have keyframes so
like literally
they would just move all the objects
quote unquote render a frame which by
the way
they couldn't render out a frame to like
a picture they could put it on a screen
and then take a picture of the screen
with a film camera
and then just do that again so it's like
literally move the objects take a
picture of the screen
like can you imagine doing a 3d
animation where the way you do it
is you position all the objects on your
computer and you hit the print screen
button
on your keyboard you open up microsoft
paint and then you paste that print
screen
copy and you save that as frame 0. and
you go back into your 3d program you
literally move everything by hand you
hit print screen again
and you do that frame by frame to make
your animation like
that's literally what they did for tron
uh the original 1982 one not for
not every company had the same exact
system but you know at least the
you know some of the companies doing
like the light cycle stuff for example
um
they had to do it that way that's why
there's no uh
that's why they're just on these maps
yeah exactly just these grids to do
to do art in addition can you imagine
doing three-dimensional
uh um perspectives
yeah yeah it's just it's so much work
and like
so we had this idea where it's like you
know what the rendering is really
straightforward like the rendering
engine that they're using it's a very
straightforward
basic basic rendering system it's been
in 3d programs forever
it's like we're like you know what now
we have all these modern tools and we
know the techniques they used
we could probably split the difference
kind of take some of their techniques
combine them with our modern tools
and we could probably remake the famous
light cycle scene from the original 1982
tron
in one day which is pretty crazy to
think about like
here's a feature film with
groundbreaking visual effects
and here we are just casually remaking
it in one day
um we set out to do that and we did we
didn't quite hit it in one day it was
like a 36 hour thing
because it turns out that like trying to
stick to their style
was almost was more time consuming than
just doing the scene you know it's like
it's like restoring an old painting
it's like when you're having to like sit
there and making sure you're using the
same materials and
you know the lines are the same
thickness and all that kind of stuff
like that ends up taking a time
but like if we just if we just like whip
up a light cycle scene
like you know with our own methods with
our own art direction and not have to
match it exactly like
we could have done it very quickly but
even even so we still did it in like
36 hours i think it's just like a
testament to like
how much the tools have been refined
how fast the computers are you know how
much more like
you know you can you can focus on your
artistry now as an
artist a lot more than you could back in
the day
yeah i mean imagine if everything had
that increase in efficiency per
man in 40 years
would be crazy imagine if like
educational tools had that increase
in imagine how easy it would be to
educate somebody
and be like you know this thing we used
to have a university for
look listen just here's one guy
okay three months and you're done
yeah you learn everything you learned
from the matrix
when when neo wakes up it's just like
yeah i know algebra
i know algebra 105. yeah it is
yeah i know biomed organic chemistry
they taught me organic chemistry why
yeah that's pretty sweet though i think
it yeah it definitely proves a really
cool point and i'm kind of curious to
see how
that stuff turned out because i'm pretty
sure you know you guys took some
creative liberties to make it look like
we didn't take any pair of liberties
oh actually well after we did the you
know after we matched it perfectly pixel
for pixel
um which we came pretty close
actually uh then we're like you know
what
peter just turn on all the nice things
like keep the
scene exactly the same because the same
animation the same models
just check all the boxes that give you
all the good stuff take the graphics and
turn them to maximum
and he did and it's pretty cool it's
pretty cool seeing the difference
between the two
nico you know what's even cooler
what the fact that today's episode is
brought to you by storyblocks
oh that is cool hey this podcast is
sponsored
yeah and five four
three three two one and once again it's
the time in the podcast where i tell you
about today's
sponsor storyblocks that's right they
are the one stop shop for all of your
stock
asset needs whether that's b-roll motion
graphics after effects templates
sound effects storyblocks has you
covered whether it's a commercial
project
a video for youtube or just a video for
yourself everything on there is in
beautiful 4k
they have such an extensive library of
content on there you will never
find or need to use the same thing twice
it's constantly being updated
storybox is gonna have what you need if
you're looking to add another layer of
quality and professionalism to
everything that you're doing so
head on over to storyblocks.com hey
that's
they're calling me about storybox do you
hear that
hey yeah storyblocks.com corridor cast
is gonna be the place
where you're gonna get everything you
need so go on there get an unlimited
all-access plan
once again that's storyblocks.com
corridor
cast all right see you out there oh okay
the telemarketer hung up on me
but seriously guys storyblocks.com or
cast
that's where you're gonna go to find
this awesome tool that we use around
here let's get back to the podcast
and that's it that's how you know that
was jake you're really good at those
sponsored segments man
thanks man i uh i haven't even done this
one yet i'm gonna do it after we finish
this episode
so wow wow remember back in the day
remember back in the day how like people
got really angry when we had sponsor
segments
yeah and like so we're like you know
what we're gonna do a couple things one
we'll put a timer on the videos
two we're just gonna go crazy with them
and that's all i think and that fixed it
you know
you can do an advertisement just make it
fun yeah just make it fun to watch
yeah it took a while as a lot of uh you
know
well especially when we first started on
youtube everyone was into such a habit
of everything being
free for everything you know it was like
you get these stories day in and day out
and there's no integrations there's
hardly any ads on the videos it was
pretty remarkable because you had
companies like machinima
and every other one that was taking
these bets like hey
we'll pay you 3.50 cpm
guaranteed every view
views are the only metric because
there's nobo there was no way else to
um bet on what youtube was going to be
worth
so they just took they just took views
and they were like okay great you got
views
okay we'll dollars pay you cents for
every thousand views
doesn't matter how you get them or who
watches them
because venture capital is unlimited
baby yeah
we gotta start somewhere it's not a
ponzi scheme
no i'm trying to just yeah sorry
you're telling this machinima here
[Laughter]
and sure enough you know i mean like it
did set the stage for
like the creators to be able to come in
and actually make a living at it and
eventually we had to evolve away from
that because that model isn't
sustainable but
you know i'm glad it happened yeah
because it that was the only thing to
get it off the ground
yeah i remember you know when the first
minecraft video
went viral it was like the third fourth
video on our channel
and like that combined with
you know another video here and there
afterwards doing all right
and then machinima's guarantee of i
think it was like a buck fifty for every
thousand views
i think they were giving you guys like
two no i think i think there's a buck
fifty
it was six it was that three bucks y'all
i thought it was that
two yeah i think i remember 250 was in
there for a while yeah
man either way yeah you paid a rent
and then they started doing the whole
like oh it's only monetized views and
i'm like oh
well actually that happened once they
switched to studio 71
it was such a good deal for creators at
the time it was not every creator got
the good deals remember all the
all the controversy about them signing
people into like
unlimited contracts like for everything
you create from here and out is forever
machinimas
that was in the that was in like the
2011 to 2013
yeah phase and then i quickly learned
that having like people with large
audiences
like having them complain about you is
like not a good thing
it's like even even if even if the
person's a dumb ass and they signed a
contract and said
you know everything you make is ours
forever you understand this sign that i
hear on the dotted line and they sign
they're on the dotted line they're like
later like oh i didn't know
everything was they're yours forever
this is really unfair you know and they
you know even if the person was in the
wrong
like once you get an audience on your
side
boy it's just pitchforks all over the
place machinima didn't have a chance no
yeah it really didn't plus it was like
some sort of
they didn't have another fundamental
scheme yeah i don't know if it was
verified ponzi scheme but it wasn't
oh what happened oh your camera guy
i can hear you i can hear you but i
can't see you i don't know what happened
but yeah it wasn't like like you said it
wasn't necessarily it wasn't actually a
ponzi scheme as much as like any venture
capitalist
endeavor in the united states it's a
ponzi scheme but it's definitely a
let's get a bunch of money for something
that sounds really modern
and then let's burn it and then try to
build something that seems
big so we can then raise more money and
then whoever raises it at that set
whoever gives us the money at the second
or third stage
they're the ones stuck holding the bag
we built something we sold it we
made our riches we're out you know
that's what they're yeah that was kind
of what they were doing wasn't it so 100
what they're doing
sign as many youtubers as you can to
then turn around and point at it to some
silicon valley investment firm be like
look
we have 10 000 people under our channel
we can access
30 million eyeballs at will it's a new
advertisement system etc etc
oh those aren't all independent creators
that exist on a platform meant for
independent creators try not trying to
ignore that
yeah try to ignore that part that they
can just at will
get their ad revenue from youtube and
not us you know
we're definitely providing a service
that they can't just get on their own
we're guys we're doing the right thing
here i don't think anyone else realizes
that
[Laughter]
yeah so needless to say of course they
weren't making any money
they did raise that second round i'm
pretty sure uh but i don't think they
got a third one and they are no longer
with us
they deleted the channels which is the
weird thing like just leave them up
leave them up and let the videos be
watched by people
they're no longer with us yeah
yeah like they died these dreams died
when you die your youtube channel gets
deleted and all your videos go with it
yeah by the way jake your camera's still
out i'm trying to fix it i don't know
what happened
11.9 million subscribers and zero videos
yeah zero videos
still active it's just that there's zero
videos they really deleted all the
videos
they did they deleted all their videos
so if you want to go back and watch
those rb and the chief
stop-motion videos or whatever those are
guys whoa
that's so weird
yeah yeah you would you would think that
the person holding the bag on that would
at least be like well just leave the
damn videos up
at least we're gonna make something
yeah that's weird what's the value of a
channel with subscribers but no videos
here's what they're about guys machinima
is the most notorious
purveyor and cultivator of fandom and
gamer culture
notorious they got that part right i
think they got that
man what a time you know that kind of
brings me to what i
was gonna propose the topic of this
podcast be which is
how the hell did we end up here
being professional youtubers it's not
like we went to school for it it's not
like we had any idea
what to do and here we are running a
company then we apparently kind of
have our [ __ ] figured out a little bit
just enough you know
to be around not exactly i know that we
don't have it figured out
yeah yeah yeah
um now trial and error jake is it
entirely trial and error did you just
constantly make mistakes until you got
it right
how did you get here well it's not
entirely trial and error i mean there's
definitely strategy that goes into
repeating
processes that work like that's
i mean you do that in anything right you
get an a on a homework assignment you're
like oh
i'm going to study the same way for the
next one
um so you do that with filmmaking i
think
um you do with writing
uh but uh it's trial and error
yes trial and error uh
backed by offset it offset by
um writing down things that work and
repeating them
uh offset by um
working hard you know just showing up
every day
and and like putting in the effort
a lot of people suffered from
well it's weird at
in your 20s when you're in a certain
industry
you'll see people sort of succeed and
and or fail at things um i mean i i you
know i suppose this happens at any stage
in life but i think it's even more
poignant when you're in your 20s because
you are coming off of this like
knowledge base
from uh you know you're no longer a
child
um now it's time to like actually start
figuring figuring your [ __ ] out
as it were figuring yourself out
figuring your career out figuring your
your skills and fortes out some people
hit that really early and you know
they can become wildly successful but
then
we've seen that happen to people we've
seen people become wildly successful at
youtube and then
and then now they're no longer maybe
they're not even in the game anymore
you know maybe they're like off doing
something else or
or they had some sort of like uh
you know faux pas when it came to like
who they are or what they what they did
you know you got your you got your toby
turners of the world and what have you
um like what's ray what's ray william
johnson up to
well he's making instagram videos he's
like is he
trying to relive the glory days but like
he gave it up
remember yeah yeah and then i think he
realized that
he can't just make i i mean i'm sure
i'm not sure how much he realized he
enjoyed it versus how much he realized
that
being the number one youtube channel is
not something to just
be like oh whatever i can do that again
if i wanted to
yeah you know right so
so there's that like realizing that uh
that uh you know just showing up every
day and putting in the effort
to to make the wheels turn on on the
thing
is is honestly just such a huge part of
the process that i can't
reiterate how important it is um
especially when you're tempted
uh when you have initial successes
you're tempted to
want to say oh well maybe i
maybe i don't need to do that anymore
because
uh i'm having success um
there's there's there's a tendency to do
that especially when you're young and
we've seen it happen to people um and a
lot
and some of them either aren't with us
uh in the youtube game
or they uh um
you know or they moved on to other
things or
or they had that period of struggle and
then they figured it out and they came
back
it's all of those any one of those
things is possible
yeah i mean it's also like evolving and
changing has been a good
part of this whole process as well which
is like
yeah like a lot of the stuff we do
because it comes
back to a lot of like the core
fundamentals of why we're interested
in doing what we do you know yeah but
at the same time it's not like
you know you get known for a certain
format
and if you pigeonhole yourself too much
in that one format
it's like well the moment you stop doing
it then suddenly it's like
like everything you're doing rests on
whether that succeeds or fails than the
new endeavor so to speak
right and so i think like for me anyways
it's definitely the the like in it
previously it would kind of hurt hurt us
in a way maybe if it may i don't know if
it actually hurt us but
like the idea of like here's a new
different idea for video
every single time we're doing it we're
always never repeating the same thing
twice
like i think you know early on that was
successful because it was like here
here's something really fresh every
single time
yeah you people you're getting people
talking about your stuff yeah
yeah i mean obviously there were
probably moments there where we could
where we could have strategized to
capitalize on successes a little bit
better but like making a second real gta
there's entire channels dedicated to
just doing the real gta style video
that we pretty much invented and then
the channels go on to like raking 20
million 30 million views per video and
just like jeez that's as much views as
we get across like all of
our videos in the entire year yeah
i mean are they still doing that are
they still getting 30 mil
no but there are channels that still do
it and no they walked into a gutter
and there was a sound and then they
never came out
yeah they're like little mini mini gold
rushes
for youtube yeah yeah but yeah
there's there's always been those we've
seen them come and go you know we've
seen the
uh the reply girls we've seen the
pranksters
we've seen the the true let's players
yeah i've seen the kids channels
the those mini gold rushes man those
little money bubbles yeah
i mean they've sprung up time and again
the vlog
era family vloggers now the family i
mean flaming vlogging is still a thing
but
yeah but it's like it's all been like
the huge spikes of like
where the algorithm and like money
combined where someone's like oh if i
just do this thumbnail
these people watch it and if these
people watch it this gets flipped in the
algorithm and it gets 20 million views
i'll do that over and over and over and
over and i'll make 10 million dollars a
year
like yeah for a year
for a year well for three years until
youtube gets off their butts
yeah and then you're good you can retire
which is
how it happened you know for some people
part of you know it's weird like
being did you guys ever feel envious or
jealousy or just like man
we should have just done that you should
have said [ __ ] it and just like
you know just raked it
you know it's the thing is like it's not
envious because it's like hey i should
have done that
i i've never felt like hey we we should
have done that and i'm envious because
or i'm jealous rather because we didn't
i always felt a little bit of resentment
i guess you could call it or anger
though because it was like i knew
how hard we worked to maintain
like a recurring but also
like fresh audience slate of content
stuff that i feel like had a little bit
of artistic value
had a little bit of something new for
the audience had a little bit of
something to say
um you know did things a little bit
differently and it wasn't just
purely existent to take advantage of the
algorithm to make as much money as
possible
to not care at all about who who watches
it or how they watch it but just to
simply
a like another like a computer meeting a
computer it's just like
here's what you want here's what i got
let's meet and have a money baby and
then
you know when you get sick of me and i
get sick of you then
we'll go on our separate ways like
i always felt you know we were giving
something a little bit something back to
the platform
uh and yeah it was a little bit it was
it's been a little bit disappointing to
see like okay well
you know not not that i'm complaining
but just to think like oh well
that person went out and made this and
they
made that much money and then they
walked away and they didn't do anything
for the platform
other than help it sell ads which then
eventually advertisers decided they
didn't want to sell on those videos
whereas we were like hey let's like yeah
youtube like let's do the thing and like
let's make the platform better and okay
okay this is what your ecosystem is like
okay we'll participate in that and we'll
make stuff that's like
that hits on those things and like okay
you know we'll give something fresh to
the audience but also try to keep it
consistent with what we know advertisers
are going to enjoy and what
the what's going to be good long term
and then to be like oh yeah that's right
we still got to do brand integrations
okay got it you know um
yeah so it's not like i'm complaining
but
it's just there's a there's a there's
something that could have been done
better there yeah
it's obvious i mean anyone can be
envious
of others success but at the same time
like you know i think the real the real
thing that speaks to that is that you
know we've we've had countless
opportunities to like go in that
direction
and haven't yeah i think the reason for
that
is just that you know you don't want to
turn something you enjoy
into your own job
yeah if you close off all the like if
you put constraints on yourself too hard
like that
then suddenly yeah you
you become your own self-hating boss for
like committing
to doing something too much you know
like
i mean i don't know and some of the
people that have done that though i
don't know if they do
feel that way maybe they're not i don't
know maybe think about it the way that
we do well i mean obviously
you know you have like you know you can
take like some examples like the paul
brothers
so to speak where it's like they're not
you know they're just doing vlogs you
know so it's like they're not
necessarily putting themselves in
constraints there but you know you look
at the other like
genre video channels of all sorts
and i would imagine that like if if
they're not just
living life and vlogging and being party
animals and stuff then like they
probably
do feel that stress of like all right
well i'm
i gotta produce this the same thing that
that
tries to you know like i'm not making
something because i enjoy making it
you know like i'm sure everyone comes to
that point
i feel like uh i feel like mr beast is
like the perfect example of that
from do you think he really doesn't like
it he must like it
i've i i heard an anecdote from an
anonymous source
who worked on a set of one of his recent
videos
and apparently he's completely
checked out of interacting with everyone
and is the the most
the most pleasant way to put it is that
he's difficult to work with
i i don't think we should speculate on
that super hard
because we speculated on him in the past
and it was not it's not
it wasn't kind and it wasn't it also
wasn't like we didn't go about it in the
right way
so well i'm look i'm not speculating
okay
uh the only thing i'm speculating is his
attitude towards the videos
but what i said about the you heard
through a third party source that that
was
from someone who had firsthand
experiences got it
got it yeah so okay and
you know whether whether or not that's
that's a true story or not i think
there's stories like that
that are true all over the place and i
think that's the truer point
and also like
even in our own content we
need to make sure that we're checking
ourselves to make sure that we're not
falling into that
you know like we we
like can you imagine if we were still
doing like
the two-week videos for corridor and in
the exact same way that we were
not not only would that be not
financially sustainable but i think at
this point you can only put on the mario
costume so many times
yeah you know yeah um before you're just
like no i'm not i'm not putting that
thing on again and
you know as much as uh
i was sad to see carmichael go and leave
the vlogs the way that they were
i do understand why he did it and it's i
think it's because of that i think it's
because he felt like he had done
everything he could do with that
form of expression and so he decided
that it was time to move on
and i respect him for that um though it
does
you know it's like little teardrop on my
heart gives me a little teardrop on my
heart to see that
but um because i felt like there was
still so much we could have explored
and i feel like we are doing that with
the crew channel like there's still so
many things that we can explore with
that channel
and eventually you know the react format
it'll probably go away
um it'd probably go away in time uh
and and i fully expect that to happen at
some point
um because you know at a certain point
it'll become
just people will either
you know like lose the audience will
lose interest or will
or will lose interest in doing it and
there's nothing wrong with that
hopefully it's
a while from now because it's been great
for everybody and
the audience loves it and it brings in a
whole new slate of people to the channel
every week
that haven't seen our videos which is
awesome
but you know you got to think
reality-wise like eventually that thing
has a shelf life
[Music]
you know there's a point where like you
know back when we were doing our thing
let's see when we we like really started
youtube maybe when we were like 23 24
years old
sure you know maybe earlier 22 yeah and
like it's starting to blow up and like
it was really the first like big i guess
gold mine
that hit when we were you know
established was the
the gamers you know right when youtube
shifted over to the watch time
and so then like video gamers started to
blow up and people like pewdiepie so
they went from like you know
nobody to making you know 15 million
dollars a year and just ad revenue
on youtube um and there's a question
where it's like all right
you know you could try pivot really hard
and pursue some of this stuff that's
like popping off
maybe find success in it but what do you
where do you want to be 10 years from
now
like what do you want to be doing with
your time
right and like here i am 10 years from
that point now
in life i look back on it like i'm
really happy with where i am
i'm really happy with the experiences we
got to have and
like every day i still get to like
sculpt a lot of my daily experience at
corridor
with you guys to be things that are
fulfilling and fun really like speak to
the things that i want to do
versus like you know grinding out my
8 000th minecraft video you know or
whatever and
you know if people like make minecraft
videos and have you know that's what
their dream when they were 24 and now
they're 34 and they're still doing the
same thing if that's what they want to
do then more power to them but like
i definitely knew that like there's a
point where if i want if i wanted to
chase the money
like at some point you'll either have
made the money or not
and then that rush is over and even if
you made the money you still have to do
you're still alive you still have to do
something with your time
right and like you know at least for us
like
it's all about that fulfillment of like
actually creating things that
people enjoy watching and like that you
know reaches out to people and
motivates them inspires them makes them
feel something you know it's
it's the artist's dream that's been
around since forever it's just part of
being human
and you know at least when i look at
that that's how i comfort myself
thinking that we made the right choice
now and it's not like we've been it's
not like financially
it's been hard like we have you know
there's moments there where
we've had to like you know really watch
the
the spending and watch the pocketbooks
and like make sure that
things are being specific um and
and and all that stuff but like we just
spent
you know all that money renovating
studio three so we can move up there and
it's this really beautiful awesome
workspace now
um and it's you know like we've been
able to
uh you know give consistent salaries to
people over the course of many number of
years
and to ourselves and it's not like you
know it's like
we're making videos man you know like
that that's we're lucky enough to just
be doing that
you know and so like the whole idea of
like getting rich
i just i never bought it you know
because
like there's no end to that way of
thinking
it's just like oh well now that i've
done that
you know what else do i want what more
do i need it's just
we've been we've done plenty fine when
it comes to that side of the game
and so i've got no regrets there it's
like super it's super cliche to say this
and i apologize
i'm gonna say this cliche but like you
know
there's the first phase in your life
where you're just trying to make ends
meet right you're just trying to pay
your rent
trying to make sure your bills are
covered so on and so forth
yeah at some point ideally you move on
from that phase of your life a little
bit you'll still have to worry about
your bills you'll start to worry about
making your ends meet but
you know once you've done it for 10
years in a row it's like
you stop stressing so much about the
next month you know if you've if you
paid your rent
for you know 300 months in a row
yeah and you learn a few things along
the way you don't make any decisions in
haste
you know and then and then you reach a
point where
the more money doesn't get you happiness
where you you realize that there's
things that you want
or there's you know there's desires that
are inside you and maybe you don't even
know how to fulfill them
but having more money isn't going to do
anything to and like i said this is
super cliche and i was like well i sure
would be happy if i had a billion
dollars
it's like i'm not i'm not saying that
having your resources covered
wouldn't would make you happier but like
for most people at a certain point you
cross that line
um where it's like okay my resources are
covered i have my shelter i have my food
you know it's like you're and that's
taken care of and at some point like
you still have to live and like fulfill
the things that you want to fulfill
and you know at least i feel like what
we've done with corridor is we've
built a relatively flexible like world
that encourages us to go out and
do the like do the endeavors that we
think are important to do
and we're supported by people that think
the endeavors that we're doing
are important and like that in
and of itself is to me almost worth more
than like any paycheck
you know the fact that like because it
is
it is it is at the end of the day like
you know you can't take any of the money
with you when you die
no you know it's not about the money
it's about it's about doing the things
that make you feel happy and fulfilled
and those things can only be fulfilled
you know through like your your own
self-fulfillment and there's no there's
no legacy of just like
being rich i mean by and large
it's not like it's not like you get
remembered because of how much money you
have even people that are
billionaires don't get remembered
because of how much money they had they
get remembered because of the
the tangible successes that they brought
to be
in the world you know jeff bezos isn't
going to get remembered for being a
whatever he is now a a 40 billionaire
or however much money that guy has in
stock and everything else like
he's going to get remembered because he
founded amazon
exactly um he took a he took a online
bookstore and made it the largest online
distributor
of goods in the history of the world
that's why and so like even when you're
talking about
like uh money and stuff it's it's really
that's
the thing that you should be focused on
is success and success is subjective
yes to to the individual but once the
individual has defined the success it
becomes
objective to that person so you can
you can define success and say like okay
you know we want to have this many
subscribers on the website
or we want to make this show with the
website um
or we want to you know have this person
as a guest on the react show
all of those things are tangible
measures measures of success that
you constantly have to be sort of
reminding yourself of
and as long as those things are in line
with
the rest of your goals sort of and
they're working in tandem
and you can actually make money off of
those things
at the end of the day then the success
on the money side will will will happen
it's just you know it's like
yeah i don't know you just so if you if
you're running the race for that
you're never gonna you're never gonna
get to a place where you're happy
maybe it's a tangent but
so so then what is
okay so if we're talking about a level
of success here
okay what's the success of
releasing like intangible
internet videos you know what i mean
like
what's sure well what did we do what was
your measure of success when we started
those videos
my measure of success was like are we
making enough ad revenue to
focus on survive just making these
videos
yeah like that was the measure of
success so self
it was completely like survivalist like
can i yeah support myself yes
step one was that can i make videos full
time yes
yes exactly that and that was the
measure of success now that was a direct
correlation to
to the amount of money that those videos
brought in but that wasn't
it wasn't the money that you were after
it was the freedom to be able to go
and then make another one yeah and have
that have the
sovereign individual like freedom to be
able to go and do that and to have that
lifestyle that was the measure of
success
and obviously that requires money
because everything requires money so
it's
it's only tangible to think like okay
well this is my measure of success
individual freedom to make videos for a
living how much money do i need to do
that
okay so i need to make x amount of money
so these videos need to make x amount of
money in order to me to facilitate me to
be able to do that
now that that's a normal train of
thought
you do have to be careful about
catching yourself in a cycle where
you're just making the videos to make
the money
to make the videos to make the money you
know because after you establish that
that
that free that lifestyle freedom then it
becomes about like okay
now now where do we go from here you
know
not to mention that question of all
right if i make one video a week
i make this much money if i make two
videos a week i make this much money
three videos a week means three money
like how hard are you gonna go on this
because at a certain point you just have
to decide to stop working and therefore
stop making money
and that's like yeah like most like most
tasks
like most people like most jobs yeah
yeah
yeah you do hit a limit obviously of of
human endurance i mean ideally you're
not pushing yourself to that
limit of human endurance just to
discover that
two videos was enough like it's more
that you know
it's like going on a vacation right if
you if you're gonna take a break from
work let's say you're working an hourly
job right
and you're gonna take you're gonna go on
a a two-day vacation so you're taking
two days off maybe a monday and a friday
i'm going to really round out this
this imagination okay dean's our example
so dean's going to take two days off
he's packing it around a weekend to
maximize
maximize his time off and get four days
off now if you're working an hourly job
at some point it's gonna pop into your
mind i'm gonna sacrifice
x number of dollars on friday i'm gonna
sacrifice x number of dollars on monday
in other words it's going to cost me
i'm just throwing a number three hundred
dollars on friday when i'm gone it's
gonna cost me 300
monday so my vacation is gonna cost me
six hundred dollars on top of all the
other things i'm gonna spend my money on
for my vacation
vacation because he's a paid he gets he
gets paid vacation
right now here's the thing when you are
your own boss
well guess what no one's paying you
anymore so if you take a vacation
it's coming directly out of your pocket
right but the thing is the moment you
start thinking about your vacation
as costing you money just because you're
not working
you're setting yourself down a bad
rabbit hole the moment you go if i take
a day off it's costing me 300
like you can't think that way like your
life will fall apart yeah like
if you're not working it's it's not
costing you money right obviously i get
this opportunity cost et cetera but if
you're not working it's not costing you
money
you're just not making money they're
they are different
and they're subtly different but they
are different and like
wrapping your head around that whether
it's your own actually true or just
psychologically true
because i think that's more
psychologically true than it is actually
true
i mean there are two distinct different
states of existence
you know one thing costs you money the
other thing is not actively making you
money like
if i go and i buy an item that costs me
money
if i don't buy an item it's not like
i've just made ten dollars because i
didn't buy a ten dollar item you know
it's like
they are subtly different what about
like a production though
because the production is like it costs
x amount per minute
but then you turn around and you like
make a video and then that video is
going to make money
because it does x y or z see you're
going you're going down the rabbit hole
i'm talking about here like so when
you're
when you are your own boss and you
decide to take a day off you think
yourself
oh [ __ ] this day off just cost me x
number of dollars
and you get in reality you just didn't
make that money
it's not like you spent it you know it's
not it's not like it you know there's a
price tag on the day
granted you're not making that money
it's just you're it's it's the same
thought it's like if you would have been
born if you had been born a day sooner
and you would have had one extra day of
work well guess what you would have just
made some extra like
that's the mentality that you fall into
like and you don't want to be in that
mentality because
if you're going on vacation and you're
now thinking about taking a day off is
costing you money you're ruining your
vacation
and you can't think like that yeah like
when you're not making money it's not
going down it's flat
you know it's like that's kind of how
you want to approach it when you want to
take your next step and continue your
climb up the mountain
like good but standing still is not
going backwards
standing still is different you know
what the best vacations are for me
when no tell me when
it's like would work and sam get up and
they do their goddamn work
no no when we're coming off one of those
epic like weeks you know where like
we got you know everything's like like
tuned in creatively
everybody's firing on all cylinders like
we release a bunch of videos
throughout the week like they're
performing well like
and i frickin and i go okay that was
great that was awesome
you know and whether it's like meeting
up or
you know whether it's like just having a
beer and just like chilling
that that that those couple of hours
when it's like
done when i'm done for the week and i'm
gonna just chill
before i go to bed honestly it's like
the best vacation and i know i'm not
going anywhere and i know i'm not doing
anything but the way it's just the way
that my mind works
i don't need that much time you know
like i don't i don't
i like to i like to get into it and like
mess around with things and like tinker
with things and like i don't know it's
just part of my
it's just part of my being yeah man
you're one of those lucky people who's
who whose life is not something they
feel like they need to get away from
no no yeah yeah man
like that that moment after like
everything's been done
and you just get to step back like i did
it and it's it's good
and it's working and everybody's doing
their thing like it's really fulfilling
i mean
hey you're sitting there you're sitting
on the keystone of your maslow's pyramid
or hierarchy of needs right there
self-actualization
achieving one's full potential
that's the very top of the pyramid yeah
and that's just
that's to me that's the best and it's
more it's more fun seeing other people
succeed
you know and like obviously being a part
of that success and helping
helping facilitate it and like you know
having your own successes along the way
in a number of different facets but like
i don't know it's just fun like watching
somebody else
you know watching clint like slam on a
video
and then see it come out see it do well
you know or watching him take that hit
and maybe it didn't do well
you know and then he's got to come back
to the drawing board but the next time
yeah um that's super fun to see
too i i
yeah i love that yeah i mean that's the
most rewarding thing you can have i
think in
in this business you know it's art man i
still say we're all artists
you know it's like if you make a cool
work of art and people are like that's a
freaking rad statue you made and you're
like yeah
cool it was a lot of work and it feels
good to be done i'm glad you like it and
like that one moment right there that's
that's
all that's all you want
that's all you need yeah dude i remember
when you're making lifeline
i think is the producer or the
showrunner of lifeline
was like look in reality the best you
can hope for is that people just watch
it quietly for two hours
like when you make a movie that's the
best you can hope for is that people go
to the theater they sit there they watch
it quietly and passively and then they
leave
if you've done that that's that's
success as an artist
you got no rounds of applause no
cheering just
silent attention for two hours and
that's it
is that a rough prospect or is that is
that
daunting it's a little disheartening
i'll be real you'd hope that people at
least like tell their friend about it
you know hey i saw this really cool
weekend or i saw this
film over the weekend i think that's
just the way that's just a way to kind
of
mitigate the failures a little bit
[Laughter]
no one no honestly no one truly
wants that i mean maybe it fits your
first thing sure but
well wait wait wait wait wait how many
people are silently sitting in
through two hours of this i mean i'm
sure there's like 99
of people is it like two or is it like
two billion
well in today's class yeah two people
are in the theater it's it's a success
oh my god uh because if it's like 200
million
like if you can get 200 million people
to sit and silently watch your video
in a theater that's a smash success
i guess the question is whether or not
they paid for the tickets well assuming
they paid for the ticket
yeah i don't know man i'd rather hear
the laughter of one audience member than
the silence of
hundreds you just
like do you want to come over and watch
my video
no man no last time it wasn't very good
yeah but
i could come you could come over and i
could sit like this and watch it
watch you while you watch it you know
speaking of watching people watching
your videos it's weird how you can kind
of like
you can tell exactly how engaged they
are even if they're not saying anything
or doing anything
yeah like they can be like sound they
can be watching your video like sitting
there
soundly yeah or their eyes a little bit
wider they can kind of be leaned in a
little bit
and just like you can feel that
difference you can tell when somebody's
like
engaged and that's when they're quiet
and that's why they're quiet or they're
just bored and being respectful and
that's why they're quiet even though
it's
it seems very similar you just tell
every time yeah every time
yeah well for us i guess our metric of
success then
is uh how many people rapidly hit their
keyboard
after watching the video or tap on their
phone screen
so what is that's okay well so
originally let's just
go back to that real quick originally we
wanted to be able to do this
full time that was our measure of
success okay
after we after we were able to do it
full time
what was the measure of success after
that like
you know think of think think akin 2014
corridor channel dude that was your
bacon remember it was your measure of
success then yeah there was the pack of
bacon
no no like 2014 corridor
our measure of success was like well we
we got a
2014 corridor man what a time i'll be
honest
like i thought it was gonna be like an
emotional reaction because of some
narrative thing like wow this is moving
or this was scary or
that was super funny you know it's like
going after like the true raw
like impacts that pieces can have
yeah and personally i didn't i didn't
realize what it was until
like the boston dynamics videos came out
and like seeing that impact so to speak
like
that that emotional reaction like
for me that it took 10 years of making
videos to get to that point for me
because after seeing that reaction i was
like ooh it wasn't just people going oh
sweet graphics bro it was like anger
and sadness and like hatred and
excitement
and like it was just like primitive you
know yeah and yeah
i'd argue you only get that you can only
get that emotion
with the style of filmmaking
that has been developed you know
partially by us and of course many many
other people in
in the online space but like it's really
hard to get that same reaction with
narrative like with classic films and
television
to get like the same kind of like anger
and vitriol
or you know celebration that you're
getting with the boss boss town yeah
that's like masterful stuff you know
like there's like
a handful of filmmakers who can capture
that
a lot of people i think say
you know i think and i think we were
maybe maybe we were part of this and we
didn't know it
but a lot of people say like oh i want
to make narrative
which may be the case which can mean
a number of different things in and of
itself but i think what you're really
looking for
is that that response
yeah that that that that response from
somebody that like
a a true response from somebody they
watch a piece and they're like oh my god
i never thought about it that way or oh
my god was that real
or oh my god holy crap we're all screwed
uh
and actually you know any any range of
those things
but impact being we set up this target
and boom the target hit home emotionally
for the person who watched it
yeah definitely that do you think i
didn't think there's one caveat to what
you just said there jake though
i think that's one of the things that
narrative filmmakers want i think the
other thing
is the ability to focus on one project
and make it the best you can yeah with
an extended period of time
however if you think about this from the
corridor point of view right
so you'd have a video you spend a week
on vfx artists react let's say you know
you spend a week on it because each one
of those videos takes a week to make
it comes out gets a million views all
right you go all right
i want to take a year to work on a film
that year those 52 vfx artists react
videos that you skip that vid
whatever you make with that year needs
to hit as hard as
52 of those vfx artists react videos
it's like
to get 75 million views on the internet
yeah it's like it's gotta be a good
video you have one shot
no adjustments i mean that's how it was
the second boss town video when sam and
clinton was working on it it's like
that was like a three month video and
it's like this better hit
and it did it hit it hit you know it hit
three months worth of time it worked but
like
there's a lot of videos that don't you
know yeah it's like
that's the that's the that's the risky
part yeah
well guys i hate to say it i uh i kind
of have to wrap this up here
the old odd all right
the kids are starting to do cartwheels
and jump off the ceiling and
hit each other with hammers or whatever
again
all right well what i was going to say
was that the website helps us offset
that
oh yeah so we're not being facetious
we're being completely honest
yeah that risk of that that sam
that crazy old uncle sam wanted to take
on local zero
yeah is is soon to become a thing
it's halfway yeah it's halfway funded
we'll see how well that does
yeah i'm excited i'm excited for that
dude son of a dungeon i'm so excited for
also that's actually gonna be pretty
sweet too
yeah and i gotta say functional
filmmaking like the outlines are coming
together the scripts are being written
as we speak yeah well me and sam aren't
writing our scripts right now
obviously but functional filmmaking is
in development and scripting phase right
now we're gonna get that out get that in
the can first and then we're gonna move
over to son of a dungeon
uh that son of a dungeon will film after
that because we wanna do things in the
order that they were greenlit
but um yeah just so you guys know um
that's where those are at yeah oh yeah
good stuff
hell yeah brother hell yeah brother oh
yeah brother that's
that's that's what i brought back from
texas
it's a hell yeah brother have you ever
have you ever have you ever got a good
hell yeah brother
hell yeah don't hit me hell yeah brother
hell yeah brother hey yeah
brother
[Laughter]
all right guys oh boy all right thanks
listening everybody
tuning in i love reading comments
by the way if you made it to the end i
love reading the comments in the podcast
because they're
slam it down slam down that applause in
keyboard typing form
or just you know engaging you're crying
guys crying eye emoji
you're one hell yeah brother
all right i'll see you guys later all
right later later guys have a good night
later